this might be the single most
controversial chapter in the history of
Black Clover asta's new anti-magic
ability is so overpowered that he is
being referred to as the anti-magic God
but a lot of people are upset about this
new massive power up man they're also
upset about how the fight between a
major villain and the black Bulls just
ended social media is blowing up with
angry fans and then other fans who are
angry at the angry fans so we need to
talk about it all right now you guys
know how this works if you enjoy my
blackover content and you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like
and comment right now to help me out
with that YouTube algorithm and if
you're one of the over 50 of people who
watch my videos but haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a big favor
and subscribe right now we're trying to
hit 2 million subscribers that would be
insane finally this video will contain
Black Clover manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned so two chapters ago we had that
amazing moment where a crying secrete
called out to Asta in desperation and he
appeared just in time to save the black
Bulls from absolute annihilation in the
last chapter Asta did what protagonists
do and he absolutely wrecked damnation
in one shot using a combination of zetin
and the demon slasher Katana now even
though Austin's attack looked like he
just sliced right through damnation's
entire body which would obviously be a
fatal wound at the end of my video on
the last chapter I warned you guys not
to assume that damnation is actually
dead as I said back then for all we know
Asta might have just released damnation
from lucius's control just like he did
to sister Lily and guess what guys that
is exactly what happened as the
narration tells us a single stroke from
asta's sword caused the spell that
Lucius had cast Over damn nacio to
unravel remembering his past with Austin
the black Bulls demonicio can't believe
that the black black Bulls were the ones
who ended up saving him from lucius's
control but he seems relieved
nonetheless Asta tells Amnesia to sleep
now and he promises that he will wake
him up too just as he's planning to do
with sister Lily so no damnatio is not
dead and speaking of people who you
thought might be that but definitely
aren't let's move on to the rest of the
chapter asked the rushes back to where
the wounded bodies of his black bull
comrades are lying along with the bodies
of the witches ichika sakrei and fineral
are standing over everyone and socray is
still sealing all of their wounds while
finral is tending to them the witch
Queen sees what's happening and she
suddenly uses her overpowered blood
magic to encase all of the Wounded
witches and blackballs into cocoons made
of blood she had already used this spell
onasta earlier in the story and its name
is Curse breaking blood cuckoo but this
time she is using it on a much more
massive scale as she attempts to heal
everyone at the same time so by using
virtually all of her magic power the
witch Queen manages to save everyone
including those who were on the verge of
death like gray and go coach she says
that their survival is all thanks to
secrete because she was able to keep
everyone Alive by sealing off their
wounds and this is what ultimately
allowed the witch Queen to heal them
however the witch Queen's decision to
use up nearly all her power for this
spell comes at a great cost to her she
asks Vanessa to take her place as the
next witch Queen because she is no
longer capable of holding this position
when we see the witch Queen's face it is
clear that she has aged several decades
in just a matter of moments now we've
already known that the witch Queen is
actually like hundreds of years old and
it seems like she has been using her
immense magic power to keep herself
young but now that she has used up
nearly all that power she is no longer
able to keep up the appearance of Youth
Vanessa is caught off guard by the offer
to become the next witch Queen and
Dorothy unsworth actually speaks up and
volunteers to take the position of which
Queen herself this kind of lets Vanessa
off the hook since I doubt that she
would want to stay inside the witch's
Forest instead of being with her
comrades the black Bulls the witch Queen
doesn't seem to have a problem with this
and she moves on to more pressing
matters she says that the black bulls
will recover and when they do Asta has
some special trick up his sleeve Asta
confirms that he does and he thanks to
witch Queen for everything that she's
done we then see a quick flashback to
Hino in which Ryu mentions that Asta is
able to apply anti-magic power to
something such as to a sword like yami's
former Katana which became asta's demon
slasher Katana Ryu believes that if ASA
can pour anti-magic into objects like
swords then perhaps he can also share it
with other people like the time with the
demon dweller sword in the dungeon this
is referring all the way back to chapter
19 when Asta was able to combine the
power of demon dweller with Noel's water
magic basically the sword was able to
absorb Noel's water magic and then
release the water magic into an attack
directed at Ma cars Ryu believes that
now that Austin has mastered zetan and
is much more skilled at harnessing the
power of anti-magic he may be able to
pull off a lot more than just borrowing
someone else's magic and using it in an
attack Ryu believes that Asta may be
able to share his anti-magic with others
and more specifically with his allies
back in the present time Asta holds
Aloft his magic sword and says
[Music]
okay fine he doesn't really say the
He-man line but he does use demon
dweller to launch a bunch of anti-magic
beams into the other black bulls and
thanks to their Affinity to Austin and
all the time they've spent together the
black Bulls are suddenly able to become
anti-magic users not only did they all
survive but they now apparently also can
use anti-magic because Asta is sharing
it with them not only that but even the
appearance of the black Bulls changes in
order to reflect their new anti-magic
abilities their outfits and appearances
become darker some of their hair turns
black or they get new black streaks in
their hair Rouge apparently becomes a
black cat and together they all declare
that in this new form they are now the
strongest as Asta exclaims let's go save
the world this chapter comes to an end
and boy did this generate a ton of
controversy the craziness of this twist
is all that the Black Clover fandom on
social media is talking about and while
there are some people defending this and
saying that they liked the chapter a lot
of other people including people who
consider themselves to be fans of Black
Clover are either disappointed or
outright angry about what just happened
but what exactly is the problem and why
are people so upset there seem to be two
main reasons the first and less
controversial one is Tabitha's decision
to once again heal everyone including
those who were right on the verge of
death like Gray gauche let's be honest
this was a case of Tabitha using yet
more fake out deaths to add tension to
the story but that tension was
short-lived and personally I didn't feel
any tension because I knew this would
happen it's happened so many times
before we had the gaja fake out the you
know fake out the Julius fake out and so
many other times when severely injured
people were just healed by Mimosa or
miraculously recovered as a result of
some other convenient plot device now
there are people out there who will
argue that you don't have to kill off
characters to have a good story and
that's a fair point to an extent of
course there are many great Slice of
Life anime or like Sports Anime that
don't kill off characters and that
doesn't take away from their quality
however Black Clover is a battle Shonen
and it is currently in the middle of a
massive war Arc that features extremely
intense and potentially deadly magical
battles I mean the main villain Lucius
is practically a God in terms of his
insane power so if you don't kill off
anyone under such extreme circumstances
you definitely lower the tensions when
it comes to the actual outcome of the
war I've said this in many videos but I
don't feel any tension when even a
remotely significant side character is
in danger and that is not ideal when
you're trying to create a tense and
gripping War Arc also it's one thing not
to kill off your characters and it's
another one to make it look like they're
going to die like their bodies are
sliced in half and their wounds are
clearly fatal but then they just
miraculously recover thanks to some
spell or power this was clearly what
just happened with gautian gray it's a
fake out and personally I don't like it
and I do understand why so many people
are critical of this kind of stuff yes I
still like Black Clover I absolutely
love the characters and I want to see
how their story ends but that doesn't
mean that I can't accept some valid
criticism of the series okay guys give
me your honest opinion down in the
comments do these fake out deaths bother
you or do you not care Black Clover is
not the only series that has done this
of course mha and jjk and plenty of
others have done it too I mean even one
piece that are boy Pell the Falcon but
again it's totally fair to critique this
type of stuff now for the second and
bigger controversy the fact that Asta
basically became an anti-magic God who
is now able to Grant others the ability
to use anti-magic some are saying that
this is just too op While others are
claiming that this shouldn't even be
possible based on the rules that have
been established in the story if
anti-magic is supposed to nullify all
magic and Asta only wields it because he
was born without any magic then
shouldn't the other black Bulls be
incapable of wielding it because they do
have magic of their own well we have
seen instances of anti-magic working
together with other types of magic in
the past and specifically through the
demon dweller sword as I mentioned
earlier when I talked about Noel's water
magic working with Austin's anti-magic
in chapter 19. we have to remember that
anti-magic is not just an invisible
force like gravity that automatically
nullifies all forms of magic no matter
what if it was then it wouldn't have its
own attacks and you wouldn't need to
even draw it in the manga it would just
be a force that's always present around
Asta anti-magic is actually a form of
energy which has its own shape and
presence and which can be controlled and
so now that Asta has mastered zetan and
learned how to control his energy much
more effectively he is able to share
some of it with people that he is
particularly close to the demon dweller
has always been able to absorb the magic
of others and connect the wielder to his
allies but Asta has now found a way to
reverse that effect that instead of
absorbing the magic of allies he gave
them his anti-magic it's actually been
implied before that this sword can
bestow power onto others so you could
argue that this was foreshadowed with
that said saying that this insane new
anti-magic twist can be explained within
the magical world of Black Clover is not
the same thing as saying that you like
this twist or that you think it is good
writing I think it's totally fair here
to point out that anti-magic was special
precisely because only Asta could use it
and if Tabata makes it so that all the
black Bulls can now use it too it
cheapens the importance and dilutes the
uniqueness of anti-magic but at the same
time I personally think that teamwork in
battle is one of black Clover's biggest
strengths so I am kind of intrigued to
see what this ultimate black Bull's
anti-magic teamwork might look like in
the final battle I'm also curious to see
how anti-magic will be wielded by people
who were already born with other types
of magic will they somehow be able to
combine the two powers like the demon
dweller sword does or will the
anti-magic just Prevail and cancel out
their original magic attributes what do
you guys think are you on board with
Asta using the demon dweller sword to
bestow anti-magic onto his allies like
some sort of anti-magic dispensing deity
or do you think this is too overpowered
and maybe a step too far don't forget to
leave your thoughts down in the comments
below with a controversial chapter like
this that is absolutely inflaming the
fandom on social media I always like to
get a good conversation going down in
the comments if you enjoyed this video
you know what to do leave a quick like
right now and if you haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications we are
trying to hit 2 million subscribers on
this channel that would be absolutely
incredible so every single subscription
counts by the way you can also hit me up
on Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
Space Cowboys